So far, we have been developing a StateChart to describe the behavior of,
of a clock radio.
Thus far, we have used seven concurrently executing machines to
model the radio's percepts.
We have left some placeholders for
other machines we will need to complete the diagram.
We have also left out the transitions for the time being.
Let's begin to look at the events that can provide the impetus for
these transitions.
Recall that an event is a spontaneous or instantaneous occurrence.
That is, we're not concerned with its duration.
It can communicate information such as if we
turned the dial what position are we turning the dial to.
But that the state machines can be sensitive to those events taking place and
cause a change of state when they detect them.